good afternoon welcome to our panel Iraq
what next in case you're here for dr.
Phil he's next door I understand that
the title of his latest book is called
love smart find the one you want fix the
one you got so if we were to retitle our
panel we might call it Iraq war avoid
the one we got dumped the one we got to
sew or you all can come up with another
title I'm Nancy snow I'm a professor of
communications and journalism at Cal
State Fullerton I'm also senior research
fellow and adjunct professor at USC
center on public diplomacy in fact one
of my colleagues is here today Bob shear
my latest book is the arrogance
there he is my latest book is the
arrogance of American power what us
leaders are doing wrong and why it's our
duty to dissent I'm privileged to be on
a panel with these outstanding
investigative reporters several of whom
have seen war and conflict up close and
very personal and they will undoubtedly
reflect on that experience today these
four really truly some of America's best
thinkers we could possibly have
discussing this subject let me introduce
them collectively and then I've asked
them to comment briefly about three to
five minutes with some opening thoughts
about what we can anticipate with this
question what's next Chris Hedges who is
at the far end was a 15-year foreign
correspondent for the New York Times and
formerly its bureau chief for the Middle
East his best-selling book war is a
force that gives us meaning was a
finalist for the national book critics
circle award for nonfiction he was a
member of the 2002 team that won the
Pulitzer Prize in explanatory coverage
for the New York Times coverage of
global terrorism on mate 17 2003 two
weeks after Bush's mission accomplished
speech aboard the USS Lincoln Chris
Hedges delivered a commencement address
i'm sure many of us will remember at
rockford college in rockford illinois
and i wanted to remind him what he said
then see if it applies today we are
embarking on an occupation he said back
in 2003 that if history is any guide
will be as damaging to our souls as it
is as it will be to our prestige and
power and security hedges has described
war as the most potent narcotic invented
by humankind his other books include
what every person should know about war
losing Moses on the freeway in his
latest book American fascists
t christian miller to the second person
down the line here is an investigative
reporter for the LA Times he was the
only journalist in the u.s. dedicated
exclusively to covering the Iraqi
reconstruction in nearly two years of
following the money trail Miller's work
has been followed by the expulsion of a
top Pentagon official the cancellation
of a major arms contract and the
initiation of several investigations The
Washington Post called his book blood
money one of the indispensable books on
Iraq and it was named a top nonfiction
book by the LA Times San Francisco
Chronicle and the Washington Post
william longer be she is the author of
five previous books including American
ground which was voted one of the becks
best books of the year by the New York
Times San Francisco Chronicle Boston
Globe LA Times and publishers weekly he
is currently international editor for
Vanity Fair and was four years a
national correspondent for The Atlantic
Monthly his current book which you'll be
able to sign is the atomic bizarre the
rise of the nuclear pore welcome and
last but not least here to my left
Robert Scheer is the founding editor of
truth digg.com which has earned three
Webby Award nominations in the
categories of news politics and
political blogs Shearer said we're one
of the few sites that actually pay to
send journalists around the world to
places like Afghanistan Iraq and Gambia
to cover stories he's thrilled to be
nominated in the news category alongside
the BBC NPR Reuters and salon.com
Shearer has covered presidential
politics for the LA Times for 30 years
he's the author of six books including
with enough shovels Reagan Bush and
nuclear war and America after Nixon the
age of the multinationals co-author of
the five biggest lies Bush told us about
Iraq and his latest is playing president
he is a clinical professor of
communications at the annenberg school
at the University of Southern California
I'm going I'm going to ask T to open it
up and give us a brief overview of
what's next and i'll be coming back to
what's now although i think this
audience has a good idea of what's now
so let's try to get to what's next good
afternoon and I wanted to thank
everybody for coming we were talking
backstage hear about what is there left
to say about Iraq's and so much is known
about it and I think the presence of so
many people here shows there's still a
lot of unanswered questions and people
really have Iraq still on their minds so
I think it's heartening to me at least
to see how many people have turned out
for this event because Iraq certainly
remains one of the most important issues
of our time so what my particular piece
of the puzzle was about when I was
working with the Los Angeles Times
covering Iraq was I like to say it's
sort of what came after hubris and
before the fiasco it was the part of the
the Iraq effort which was to rebuild
Iraq and turn it into a thriving and
sparkling example of democracy in the
Middle East I think there was some some
fifty billion dollars this stage of the
game has been spent on that effort and I
think you only need to look over at Iraq
right now to see how much of that was
well spent money and the answer is not
very much what the Bush administration
did is they turned over the mission of
the reconstruction of nation-building to
private companies to private
multinational companies and I compared
often to saying what if the Pentagon had
turned over the invasion of Iraq to only
private mercenaries that would have
never occurred but the rebuilding part
of it was completely turned over to
private soldiers by the mercenaries
private corporations and so what the
result was a reconstruction effort which
was motivated not by a belief or a
passion or interest in making the world
a better place but by profit and the
results were very little even a racking
today the amount of money has been spent
has not delivered electricity to Iraq it
hasn't delivered oil production to Iraq
Iraq remains a miserable place to live
and be and exist
so that money is gone and spent and I
don't that's what my that's what blood
money my book was basically about where
that money went and where it disappeared
to the topic of the panel today is is
what's next in Iraq and at least in my
part of that question which is how do
you build or is there any chance left to
do nation building to do democracy
building the evidence that i have seen
presented before me is there isn't very
much chance left we're to stage the game
where there's no stomach left certainly
in the public and in Congress either to
fund a marshal type plan nor would it
even clear that that would be possible
to do a Marshall Plan as most of you
know took place after the war was over
after World War Two and in Iraq were
still very much in the middle of an
ongoing war so the chances of being able
to do anything like what the initial
plan was to to really bring a better
quality of life to Iraqis seems to me as
distant as it ever was and there doesn't
look like there's going to be any change
in that Intel and unless there's some
settlement of the fighting in Iraq and I
can't say that there's any again any
clear signs that's going to happen any
time soon so i just wanted to open up on
that hopeful note and turn over to our
next speaker Wham well I've listening to
tea here it's a voice of experience i
would say that in among all of the
errors and assumption that americans
made and i would use i don't just mean
the US government I mean Americans
collectively made about Iraq we now know
I'm sure everyone in this audience knows
what many of them were that we would
have the military ability to deal with
an insurgency for instance we all know
this was false but the one thing that I
have not seen Americans really waking up
to and that pertains to Iraq and the
future of Iraq
is this question of democracy I mean
there seems to be an assumption that
Iraqis only still need to become
reasonable to become educated to learn
the advantages of democracy and to lay
down their weapons and stop killing each
other and that this is something which
could be perhaps still taught to the
Iraqis this has always been false in the
sense that in my experience in Iraq over
the years the Iraqis are fairly
well-educated people it's a especially
in Baghdad largely middle class society
well-read despite the restrictions of
Saddam's regime they knew and know very
well what democracy is about they
understood it from the beginning they
understood also the limitations of
democracy within Iraq so it in a way
it's always been an insult to the Iraqis
to and sort of a paternalistic thing say
now now let's be reasonable just learn
the good liberal American perhaps
left-wing view of how you should run
your society stop picking up your
weapons but in fact my experience in
Iraq has been that their assessment the
Iraqis assessment of the problems that
they face in that society was realistic
fully informed by an academic and
historic knowledge of democracy in
Europe and the United States but also
informed of the realities in Iraq which
said ultimately which dictated
ultimately as things unraveled the need
to pick up weapons so there is a reason
for war often and in Iraq there's a
reason for war today an atomized reason
it's terrible and tragic but it is not
something that's going to go away and as
far as United States goes I think
obviously there's really no solution for
the United States we've made a terrible
error our leaders did and our people did
when they reelected those leaders
and we have no we have no choice but to
continue in one way or another to pay
for those errors collectively it is all
of our responsibility to continue to pay
for the error in the future it would be
desirable if we could find a way not to
do this again and it's difficult because
we're not going to face exactly the same
situation we can look now at Iran for
instance and the the threat of nuclear
proliferation there and the urge that
does exist in American society to go to
war to stop it this is something which
needs to be examined very carefully but
the examination is not an exact parallel
to to what happened in Iraq and I think
I'll just leave it at that so William
the answer to the panel question what
next is not Iran well I would assume
given the condition of our military
right now in our political will that
it's probably not Iran right now I mean
I would say that no it's the the the the
the the future is not at least let's say
it's not an attack against Iran now
we're on of course in Iraq is a
different question but I would assume
that we are not going to repeat our
error now against Iran but the question
is in five years or ten years give it a
generation let's see what we do is there
some way that we as a country can learn
from this and not repeat it yeah first I
want to add it to my little introduction
that I life goes on after the LA Times
and when I was fired for opposing the
Iraq war the San Francisco Chronicle
picked up my column sorry
I'm grateful that and was interesting
about this panel is evidently the
sponsors couldn't find anyone to defend
the search and the current position i
noticed christopher hitchens did speak
today but on a loftier topic of the
divinity and I just remember an earlier
time when he told us everything would be
hunky-dory because his my good friend
Ahmed Chalabi would set things straight
was the way he put it naaku chaala be
you know did not get one percent of the
vote in that Democratic experience I
want to say the question of what next
should not be left up to panelists as
bright as they may be it's up to the
citizenry and it's very clear there is
an alternative a very minimal
alternative it should not be watered
down anymore but it's been presented by
the Congress to the president the
Congress has the right to hold the
president accountable for the
expenditure of funds they've put it
absolutely the minimal program of
accountability before the president if
the president vetoes it then the
responsibility should be on the
president not to have 124 billion in
additional funds which after all is not
chump change you could do a lot of good
work in this country with that money but
I think this is the real test and I
think people watching this on c-span or
listening here today should make it a
test they should back the majority in
the House and the Senate and saying this
far and no further and all they're
asking of the president they very much
watered down bill it says yes you can
continue training troops up into the
future you can do all sorts of things
but you have to account for your
progress or failure to have progress at
all it says and for the president to
veto that would show that he doesn't
want to be in the most minimal sense
accountable which goes to this question
of spreading democracy what kind of
model for democracy have we shown the
Iraqis or anyone else in the world we
have a government that is condone
torture the radical government that has
systematically lied to us we now for
know from George tenants book he said it
was a slam dunk he didn't mean it was a
slam dunk that the case for war was
accurate it was a slam dunk that you
could deceive the American public that's
his defense and he waited until you got
four million dollars to tell us this
the election and in a book and it seems
to me what's really involved here is is
the need for citizens to wake up and
wake up and say look you do not have
adults watching the store that's what my
book playing president is all about it
didn't start with this president when
Lyndon Johnson took us into Vietnam we
now know from the tapes there that he
never for a day believed in that war for
a day we know Richard Nixon from the
tapes never believed in the Vietnam War
that he escalated yet we know Robert
McNamara fog of war the documentary
never believed in Vietnam yet 3.4
million indo-chinese died in that war
that they never believed in and fifty
nine thousand American soldiers died
okay 343 soldiers have died just this
year alone 99 in April there's a reason
to think about Iraq and we're going to
flounder on this debate which can go on
for another ten years and the numbers
will increase and it's always based the
idea that somehow we are the
indispensable ingredient to making their
lives better we who have lied about
their country have deceived the world
somehow we are indispensable we're not
we are part of the problem not part of
the solution yes you can give foreign
aid yes you can support an international
effort yes we can send folk singers over
there to give peace a chance you can do
lots of wonderful humanitarian things
but the idea that a sane society will be
developed in Iraq let alone and the
general Mideast on the basis of American
military power is forced it needs to be
challenged it needs to be challenged by
decision Sri or this will go on for
another decade so right now what next is
really up to the people of the United
States and they have got to say they've
had
Chris you get to follow Bob well I think
what's next is the most important
question and I think it can be summed up
in one word impeachment
George Bush has shredded violated or
absented America's from its obligations
under international law he is refused to
sign the Kyoto Protocol backed out of
the anti-ballistic missile treaty tried
to kill the International Criminal Court
walked out on negotiations on chemical
and biological weapons and defied the
Geneva Convention and human rights law
in the treatment of detainees most
egregiously he launched an illegal war
in Iraq based on fabricated evidence we
now know had been discredited even
before it was made public the president
is guilty in short of what in legal
circles is known as the crime of
aggression and if we as citizens do not
hold him accountable for these crimes if
we do not begin the process of
impeachment we will be complicit in the
codification of a new world order one
that will have terrifying consequences
for a world without treaties statutes
and laws is a world where any nation
from a rogue nuclear state to a great
imperial power will be able to invoke
its domestic laws to a null its
obligations to others the new order will
undo five decades of international
cooperation largely put in place by the
United States and thrust us into a
Hobbesian nightmare we must not allow
international laws and treaties ones
that set minimum standards of behavior
and provide a framework for competing
social political economic and religious
groups and interests to resolve
differences to be discarded the exercise
of power without law is tyranny and the
consequences of George Bush's violation
of the law his creation of legal black
holes that can swallow us along with
those outside our gates run in a direct
line from the White House to Abu Ghraib
to Guantanamo George Bush we now know
from the leaked Downing Street memo
fabricated a legal pretext for war he
decided to charge Saddam Hussein with
the material breach of the resolution
passed in the wake of the 1991 Gulf War
he had no evidence that Saddam Hussein
was in breach of this resolution and so
he and his advisors manufactured reports
of weapons of mass destruction had
disseminated them to a frightened and
manipulated press and public in short he
lied to us and to the rest of the world
there are tens of thousands perhaps a
few hundred thousand people who have
been killed and maimed in Iraq because
of a war that has no legal justification
a war waged in violation of
international law the grief visited on
American and Iraqi families demands that
we as citizens begin the process to
restore the rule of law the murderous
rampages in Iraq demands this the
torture done in our name demands this
the empowerment of states that will act
on our lawless example if we do not
impeach George Bush and return to a
world of standards demands this simple
human decency demands this a real
rule-based world matters the creation of
these international bodies and rules as
well as the use of our influence over
the last half-century to see they were
followed have allowed us to stand
preeminent as a nation one that respects
and defends the rule of law if we
demolish the fragile and delicate
international order if we permit George
Bush to create a world where diplomacy
broad cooperation and the law are
worthless if we allow these
international legal systems to unravel
we will see our moral and political
authority plummet we will erode the
possibility of cooperation between
nation states including our closest
allies and see visited upon us the evil
we visit on others
is dr. Phil available I am I wanted to
you mentioned Bob George Tenet and I
understand that when comparing himself
to President Bush he explained the slam
dunk comment he said we sometimes say
things from our gut whether it's his
bring them on or my slam dunk so I am
I'm wondering what role maybe language
has plane rhetoric here and Karl Rove in
a question-and-answer period a few weeks
back at a speech to a Republican group
in Ohio was asked whose idea was it to
start this pre-emptive war in Iraq does
anybody remember what he said I think it
was Osama bin Laden's remember him so if
you want I can play the role of the
other side if but I think there's some
consensus here although I would like to
ask a question and what next after bush
for the second time in his
administration will veto the spending
bill what next after that I mean it's
coming this week well first of all the
tenant book as far as one can tell from
reading in the advance of the 60 Minutes
interview and the New York Times account
he goes much further he said this
administration never never seriously
evaluated the evidence never seriously
debated the question of whether there
was a risk to our security a connection
with 911 a threat of the weapons and so
forth so that's or any time ever again
in your life when you say hear someone
say they must know something they must
have information okay there must be a
reason they're doing this thing that
looks right quite stupid but after all
we have an in Central Intelligence
Agency we spend God knows how much money
because it's a secret figure on
gathering this information and here's
the head of the CIA has written a book
saying on the most important issue how
do we respond to 911 should we go off
and invade a country that had nothing to
do with it did not pose a threat to us
at that time he said never
once did they debate this issue within
the administration that's that's a
damning indictment and I don't know how
you can defend that particular devil let
me say on the question of if Bush vetoes
it I think this is a time for the
Democrats to show that representative
government means something and the few
Republicans that support them the vote
is smoked in the election of democratic
up means anything the decision about war
and how you wage it and how you how long
you go with it should be a one that's
made by the representatives and if they
cave on this and they don't deserve
their shot at power this is the time to
tell your representatives that they
should not cave on this one they have to
hold Bush accountable they are willing
to allocate what I think is an extreme
waste of money another 120 for billions
here 100 billion to Iraq okay but the
idea that they will not insist on having
guidelines for progress and
accountability for president is
unacceptable and this is a time for
people watching this show or listening
or so forth to speak out and let their
representatives know that it's
unacceptable to cave at this time anyone
want to answer that question where we go
after he vetoes the spending bill what
was the question the question was given
what's next this week in Washington
after bush vetoes the spending bill that
was just passed by both the House and
Senate where do we go from there because
of course it called for a drought of
pulling back of troops by October first
so if you could peer into the future
where might we be following this this
veto which he's promised to do well I
will all speak to this I guess but I
think Bob's basic point is that this is
a political question and anybody who has
followed the politics of it knows that
at least as of right now that there is
going to be money past I will continue
this war one way or the other and the
only way that will not occur is if there
is some general grassroots movement
along with Bob is suggesting to say no
we don't believe this should occur any
longer in our names otherwise that bill
is going to pass
war is going to continue I remember not
in our name right I mean it sounds like
there's a there's a sentimentality that
there is a collective responsibility
here that it's not a matter of
bush-cheney or spending but rather that
we as a nation need to take a collective
sense of responsibility about what
happens next is that what you all would
you would you agree on that is their
consensus I of course agree completely
with that I I think that it's a mistake
and a cop-out to to go after the
political leaders at this late stage
when the evidence has been so clear for
so long that this policy was wrong and
we need to accept it upon ourselves that
the press also obviously and the people
who deny the press and people who
discount the press even more so when
when it has been obvious for a long time
so to to expect that the reforms that
count can take place in the context of
elections and congressional votes and
this sort of thing I think is not living
up to the responsibility for what we as
a nation have done likewise a facile
withdrawal and God knows we'd all like
to get out of there now but a facile
withdrawal is another form of a cop-out
even though there is no solution
provided by staying even though we
really don't have the tools to fight
this war we can't touch the problem but
just leaving is minding our own business
so to speak denies what it is that we
have done and we really can't deny that
we shouldn't Chris you want to add and
then we'll come to Bob well I think part
of the problem is that you know we
failed to grasp the fact that we're
dealing with this an administration that
is essentially radical it has taken leon
trotsky call for permanent revolution
and sort of slightly corrupted it
she didn't a permanent war I think that
if left unchecked the possibility of
them making strikes against Iran before
the end of the administration is
certainly very possible certainly
everything is in place we know from
statements by Netanyahu and other
Israeli leaders who are now saying well
we have to wait a year and see if
diplomacy works I think that's a pretty
good indication that the administration
has put this on back burner but they
certainly haven't discarded it as a
possibility and as someone who's spent
as long as I did in the Middle East a
fair bit of time in Iran itself a war
against Iran which would be primary it
would be Ariel would you know use
missiles and conventional bombing would
have truly catastrophic consequences
within the Middle East and I think that
part of the reason that I do believe
that there should be a Citizens movement
to call for impeachment is because we
now are dealing with a minister
administration that quite effectively
has placed itself outside the law both
international law on domestic law and if
though hardline elements we know richard
perle has called for this continues to
call for this if they actually do strike
Iran that sort of rapture like
apocalyptic vision of cataclysmic
violence embraced by the Christian Right
will come pretty close to a reality the
hit against Iran would be an open war
against Shiism within the Middle East
we're already fighting a proxy war with
the Shiites throughout the Middle East
you know not only would it empower or
you know the the Shiites within Iraq and
make that cauldron of Iraq far worse but
there are two million Shiites in Saudi
Arabia most of whom work in the oil
sector bah Iranian Shia huge Shia
minority in Pakistan I'm sure Musharraf
would not stay in power Hezbollah would
become active in northern Israel Iran
does not have a capacity to hit the
United States with conventional forces
which under an Internet
law by the way if we attack them they
would have a right to do but they do
have the capacity to hit Israel Israel
would strike back the possibility of
this imploding the Straits of Hormuz
shut down oil skyrocketing you know well
over a hundred dollars a barrel the
Iranian government which and let's be
clear I mean this is not a very
attractive government as of course the
Iraqi regime under Saddam Hussein was
not would seek to empower any group that
was willing to make strikes against us
with anything from a dirty bomb to
biological and chemical agents I mean
the possibility of this and I think that
that it's pretty clear from everything
the panelists said and I would agree
that if we as citizens don't begin to
speak with one loud voice and call for
resumption of the rule of law not only
will the war continued but I think
there's a real possibility that before
the two years up it could be expanded in
a way that will haunt us for decades and
decades I'm gonna go to Bob and then do
a round of questions and then we'll open
it up okay let me just say I'll just
deal with it clearly the critical
question is you know can we leave and is
that immoral and so forth and I think I
know the word is wasted but I certainly
spent a lot of my adult life on this
kind of argument in relation to Vietnam
and it's just year after year the first
time I went to Vietnam there were
thirteen thousand troops and then there
were five hundred thousand we by the way
half as a percentage of the population
if you put the contractors in more
troops now in Iraq than we did at the
height of Vietnam but we're always told
progress was around the corner cetera et
cetera when all of those arguments fails
and all of the lies were exposed we were
told well but there's big moral argument
you can't just leave them and the
assumption is other people will make
their history in a way that's less
appealing then we will make it for them
this was the argument that Graham Greene
challenged in his quiet american that
classic book on American hubris the fact
is we make a mess of it we make a
terrible mess of it and our predictions
don't turn out to be true and no one
goes back and examines it what was the
great fear if we just
get out of Vietnam and we got out under
the most ignominious of circumstances we
could have had and negotiated withdrawal
we could do that now we can get out of
Iraq over a year and a half period in an
orderly way we can do what the Baker
Commission said and bring in the Syrians
and the Iranians and the Saudis is all
of whom are asking us to leave you know
we could do it in an orderly way we
probably won't and so five years from
now we'll be lifting people from the
roofs near the embassy as we did in
Saigon we didn't accept all those
alternative plans no one ever went back
and looked at the predictions of what
would happen after we kill 3.4 million
people what happened did Vietnam did the
dominoes fall did they conquer all those
free nations no red Vietnam and red
China went to war over a long-standing
border disputes okay and what are they
were about now space and costco and
walmart to communist governments yet
this country was traumatized for decades
politics destroyed our treasury wasted
lives of the young ruined over something
over these predictions we can't just get
out and that's the same garbage that
we're hearing now we have not the wisdom
we don't understand the language we
don't respect the history we are not on
the side of the angels in that region by
any means we do care about the oil and
exploiting it our contractors have
ripped them off every which way to
Sunday that's what's going on with this
reconstruction there are industries in
this country that benefit from war there
is a military industrial complex that
wants to keep the state of tension going
in the world most Americans don't
benefit most Iraqis don't benefit so
what I'm asking for is yes let's get out
you can get out in a negotiated way you
can involve your allies which we didn't
do you can involve the French who have
some experience and you'll get the
English to play a more vital role in the
Germans you can use international force
you don't leave at nine o'clock tomorrow
morning but the principle which is
established in that house and senate
resolution is that we are going to get
out and i don't understand the argument
that says that somehow we are the
essential ingredient to their well-being
it's like you break into a house you
rape the people in it you steal their
treasure and then you say but we can't
just go now
I had I hate to add insult to injury but
I've got another quote for you all to
respond to this is from Bush's speech to
the World Affairs Council of Western
Michigan and he said the consequences of
failure in Iraq would be death and
destruction in the Middle East and here
in America now that has worked I think
that worked as a fear tactic to win
re-election not too long ago in 04 it
didn't work in 06 public opinion polls
suggests that the American people are
really ahead of the curve now head of
this administration although they don't
want an immediate withdrawal in terms of
a majority they want troops out of iraq
by 08 so this will clearly be a major
issue in the 08 election is there a more
hopeful message I wanted to ask t you
brought up the marshall plan but then
you kind of you said it wasn't possible
it wasn't an opportunity although at the
end of blood money you said the
following the reconstruction in the last
few years after world war two had been
disastrous dubbed Operation rat hole by
critics but American diplomats and
political leaders stepped back adjusted
and created the marshall plan at the
last hour they rebuilt the
reconstruction it was not too late then
it is not too late now now what I'm
hearing though from the panel is a
possibility for it not so much to be a
Marshall Plan but rather the ability for
the people for the citizenry to make
this something beyond the what have we
heard hubris before fiasco disaster mess
is there something a little more hopeful
I'd like each one of you to address that
before we turn to the audience well to
take the take Bob as metaphor okay so
here where the robbers have gone into
this house and and and decimated I think
the the only difference that i would i
would bring up is that we're still
robbers with a lot of money and
influence and power in the world and if
we do bring those things to bear in a
way which is been more intelligent
we have done in the past which is not
unilaterally which is working with other
countries which is relying upon the sort
of experts in development and not
relying upon simply private corporations
to do the work for us as a people in our
name if we decide that there are
different and better ways to go after
finding a solution to this problem I
think there is some hope to it's not
going to be the sort of large-scale
Marshall Plan reconstruction that we all
envision sort of guaranteed a free
europe for for 40 years for 60 years now
it has to be right at this stage of the
game especially is something much more
much more smaller and something along
the ways of how do we extricate
ourselves from this situation is their
way to do that which doesn't leave
behind nothing more than a smoking ruin
I think we're two stage now where Chris
used the term proxy war and he's
certainly familiar with what Central
America was we're at a stage now where
this is a this is a proxy war and the
United States is funding its people and
Iran and Syria funding their people and
al-qaeda funding their people and the
Iraqis are in the middle of all this
trying to extricate themselves and make
lives as they want which is a better
life for themselves as I talked to many
people over that's basically what they
want the same things anybody else wants
I can't offer you any solutions I can't
tell you how to do that and I don't know
if anybody else I really can't offer a
solution to that problem for how do we
in any kind of near-term way turn Iraq
around well there go ahead you know I
mean of course you know we all want hope
I but we have to go back and and visit
what we did is a country immediately
after the attacks of 911 I was covering
al-qaeda for the New York Times based in
Paris and in those days and weeks after
the attack we had garnered the empathy
of most of the world including the
Muslim world
one-fifth of the world's population most
of whom are not Arab I was working in
the Middle East at the time and Muslims
were appalled at what had been done in
the name of their religion sheikh of
al-azhar tantowi the most important
Sunni Islamic religious institution in
the Middle East announced the crimes of
911 as for what they were crimes against
humanity he went on to denounce Osama
bin Laden as a fraud someone with no
theological training no right to issue
fatwas or religious edicts and what did
we do as a country we drank deep of that
very dark and poisonous elixir of
nationalism we folded in on ourselves
and the flip side of nationalism which
is really about self exultation is
racism and anyone who criticized us
including our allies people who share
our values like the French we ridiculed
in what can only be described as racist
terms the only way to fight terrorists
is to isolate them within their own
societies terrorism is a tactic you
can't fight terrorism the way you fight
a conventional war by dropping iron
fragmentation bombs all over the Middle
East and if we had the courage at that
time to be vulnerable if we had had the
courage to build on that empathy we
would be far more respected and far
safer than we are today unfortunately we
as a country were led astray and there
was of course complicity because i think
is Bob and probably everyone else in
this panel who if they spoke out about
the war in those early days remembers
how lonely that was there was a terrible
complicity on a large part of our
citizenry and unfortunately we have let
ourselves down to a very dark and
frightening cul de sac and it's because
of bad leadership and bad choices that
we made and I think as someone who spent
almost 20 years of his life outside the
United States I desperately
want to see those of us who care about
democracy and care about the rule of law
rise up and begin to demand both justice
for ourselves and justice for those
outside our gates that we have aggrieved
and wrong I have decided just from a
personal point of view that if we go to
war with Iran I will no longer pay my
income taxes and I have no illusion that
large numbers of people will join me or
that it will make any difference but I
have friends in Gaza in Tehran in
Lebanon who will suffer and perhaps some
of them suffer egregiously for these
decisions and at least I hope I will be
able to return when this nightmare is
over and have earned the right to ask
for their forgiveness William
as far as what might be what possible
positive outcome we might see in Iraq
none as well like I can't see any on the
street I don't mean my sense for the
streets precludes the positive outcomes
no matter what we do that doesn't mean
we shouldn't try to do it it doesn't
mean that we don't have a responsibility
at the very least to pump a lot of money
into that mess we cannot just abandon it
but the chances of something good coming
out of this no not for a long time time
course history there will be a solution
peace will come to Iraq we know that
after much suffering but I have no idea
what that piece I think no one can now
know what that piece will look like and
I doubt very much whether we can have
much effect on it yeah I just was there
I am very hopeful and and the reason is
because of what I talked about before I
mean there was a time when we were torn
apart by who lost China and the
demonization of one country after
another and as imperfect as they may be
it turns out as Richard Nixon showed we
were able to make peace with the enemy
give peace a chance it turned out to be
a pragmatic hard-headed realistic way to
look at the world what happened with the
Bush administration was the demonization
of nations at will we forgot about Saudi
Arabia even though 15 of the hijackers
came from Saudi Arabia we didn't care
where they came from how they recruited
where the money went so and so on we
picked on Iraq which hadn't sent it to
this day a single terrorist to this
country then I've heard of we played
games with this demonization now we can
be friend North Korea it's okay that
they have a weapon and some sort nuclear
weapon will do business with them but
somehow Syria we can't work with and
Iran forget it we have to make war
although we've invited them to the peace
talks next week and there they are
coming so I think things can change I
believe it's hard headed and realistic
to give peace and diplomacy a chance and
what happened in this administration is
those ideas were derided there we had
this junk science if you like from this
administration facts didn't matter logic
didn't matter
and all the values that you could shower
on some talk show and you won the day
and you and people were afraid because
of 911 so we didn't have rational
analysis you know it's like you go to a
doctor and you got a bump in your head
and he says cut off the leg so we invade
Iraq had absolutely nothing to do with
911 I am hopeful because I think
democracy will be enhanced and advanced
in this world by people in the united
states showing that democracy works
that's what happened in the midterm
election that lesson will not be lost on
the world that in the most powerful
nation in the on earth people use the
democratic system maybe was late I agree
with you and the Free Press was late to
the table but finally as Mark Twain said
you know a lie gets halfway around the
world before the truth puts his pants on
but finally truth couches up and I could
think of no better argument for
democratic values for limited government
for constitutional restraint than the
fact that the US Congress has finally
passed a resolution holding this
president accountable I think this is an
incredibly hopeful moment and we should
cheer on pelosi and reid and all the
rest that have had the guts to do that
and make sure they have popular support
at this key moment and i'd also like to
add to that look at everybody in this
room today how filled this room is and
that I see is really a message of hope
that you still care about this issue and
that you're willing to get involved on
it you haven't given up as so many of my
friends have they just shrug their
shoulders let's go to a few questions
and again a question only you'll have
time to speak to the author's afterwards
at the South signing area line Z but
let's briefly go to questions only thank
you I propose the topic and looking
ahead to the election the presidential
election what hope can you offer for us
when never mind the Republicans the
top-tier Democrats as Mike Gravel so
aptly put it have all embraced the
notion of wars of aggression as
something they will opt for
apropos mr. hedges point they all okay
brace this that's your question who
would Chris well I think you raise a
good point you know and as Bob said
there are powerful interests remember in
this country that want this war they're
making a lot of money off it I you know
I think it's incumbent upon all of us
not to support a candidate who is not
unequivocal about denouncing the war but
I think even more importantly denouncing
the kind of corporate interests in the
corporate state that makes the
perpetuation of war possible and I don't
see anybody in the democratic party
who's doing that the only person who who
has done that has been you know sort of
vilified and largely destroyed by the
Democratic Party and that's Ralph Nader
quick question thank you yes it's a
question to mr. hedges and Mr Shearer
last year I'd asked about the Walt
marshana paper on the pro-israel lobby
and had pushed it to us to war in Iraq
and is and is doing the same with Iran
it's a war for Israel as a primary can I
get a response or mr. sure this year at
least and mr. hedges you'd mentioned
Richard Perle he's part of the Jewish
institute for national security affairs
and if you read the new biographical
book about Colin Powell listen Karen
DeYoung says the jinza crowds in charge
of the Pentagon the new The Washington
Post editor Karen are young why are we
talking about this mr. sure you can
answer this one truck I'm moderator and
I want you to please sit down answer I
should answer in the words of Ronald
Reagan I'd paid for say so fortunately
fortunately in the latest Wolfowitz
affair the Jews have been absolved of
responsibility since he has a Muslim
lover who was very instrumental and this
and I think when we look at my view on
the neo-cons is with friends like that
Israel doesn't need enemies you know I
think anybody who thinks this kind of
policy has been good for Israel or that
the Israeli public would support i think
we find a lot more support for what we
said on this panel in the Israeli public
and even deedn't in the Israeli media so
don't think the problem with the
neoconservatives is so some kind of
pro-israeli cabal of an at all i think
the problem there is that these people
are you know as Chris pointed out
believers in permanent revolution and
they managed to convince Bush that this
was a great way of advancing his career
being more successful than his father
rejecting his handlers that his father
had supplied and in fact we I haven't
said anything tonight that is really
very different than what the Baker
Commission came up with you know the
radicals are the people in the White
House and what happened was that people
like Richard Perle you know and the
others fights and you could go down the
list that these people had a radical
agenda they didn't believe even in
George Bush's seniors a new world order
they didn't believe in trade they didn't
believe in negotiations or any of these
things that were being pushed they
didn't accept the wisdom of the first
Bush administration don't seize Baghdad
and the whole idea of you very good you
own it and all of the sense of
obligation and they went with a very
small group of people that are wonderful
at panels wonderful in college lectures
but they should never been in command
control of the Defense Department is
absolutely outrageous so we've had these
radicals in power and it's time to stand
up to my want to make one other point
here about accountability and the media
the last week we had incredible
testimony before henry waxman's
committee about jessica lynch and Pat
Tillman and that made page 10 of the LA
Times and it did not make the New York
Times that is a scandal I just want to
second that by saying that it's
important I mean I you know not only you
know I lived in the Middle East for a
long time including in Jerusalem that
what we're talking about is within
Israeli society a small radical
messianic group and it it you know I and
as Bob said I think correctly there's
far more debate and understanding not
only about the war in Iraq what about
the horrible repression meted out
towards the Palestinians within Israel
than there is in the United States but
what we've seen is an alliance between
messianic jews and israel and messianic
christians and neo cons in the united
states who believe that they have been
given
are anointed to have a divine or or have
a diviner moral right to rule the Muslim
world but those people don't represent a
majority of Israelis just as I don't
think these people represent a majority
of Americans expression I think what
what I would like to see in the future
that the things that we not to do the
same thing we've done in the past
overthrowing governments like dr. Masada
and Iran are bonds in Guantanamo and
descending the military junta on people
like in Greece with it okay so how can
we get to a point of not having an
empire and being a country so we don't
have to inflict wounds and pain and
suffering on other people for the way of
our lifestyle has to be you're looking
at me you're the stool all panelists
I'll take down look I think history
matters and you know the country's don't
just become important when we invade
them and then we forget about them I
mean who gives a damn about Vietnam
unless it's the person cutting your hair
or doing your nails somewhere and
they've now building their retirement
home back there and they follow it they
can read online 10 different Vietnamese
papers but fact a fact is for all the
debate about that country most people
here don't don't care about what the
quality of life or freedom or what have
you and I think there has to be a sense
of accountability you know and the their
lives matter and maybe out of that will
get some sense of respect that they may
be the best people to make their own
history it won't always be a good one I
think there are times when you should
intervene internationally to stop
genocide when you don't want a broad
support know what you're doing know your
hands are clear you're not stealing the
oil etc etc yes but in the main I think
we should be cautious in intervening and
I want to say on a personal note I
remember one of the first stories I did
for the LA Times I interviewed a guy
named kermit roosevelt who was a sadly
enough dying that time point in the
hospital his wife gave me his phone
number and I asked him I said could you
please tell us in the readers of the LA
Times how you overthrew Massa day and he
very cheerfully told me the story I put
it on the front page of the paper it
hasn't changed anything we never asked
the question how when after we overthrew
the lab
Sekulow popular leader of Iran do we
have any responsibility for the mess
that came after did we do anything wrong
in relation to that country you know we
never asked those questions takes honor
hussein in today's LA times it says
cenamos same was found guilty of crimes
against humanity events that took place
in 1982 does anybody point out that the
crimes he was convicted for were all
known before Donald Rumsfeld went over
there and shook his hand and the
alliance with the United States began
with Iraq we owe none of the sense that
you can learn from history and not
repeat these mistakes and that's what's
happening right now we've got three
minutes unfortunately so I really
applaud Chris Hedges statement calling
for impeachment and wanted to ask him
about the international impact this was
have to have because I feel we're in
this death spiral between imperialism
and Islamic fundamentalism and we have
to as baba vacants are you bring forward
a different way that's neither nice
macworld orgy ha let me address that I
mean I the reason why I believe a
citizen call for impeachment is
important is because it's really a call
for the restoration of the rule of law
and implicitly a desire to rejoin the
community of nations which we have
allowed this government to upset our
selves from in a variety of protocols
and treaties and statutes that you know
since the end of World War two attempted
to create a rule-based world a world
where nation-states had to abide by
certain standards and I think it's
extremely important for us as citizens
to make our voices heard not only within
the confines of our own country but
abroad so that people understand that
there is this kind of yearning to be
part of a wider community that we can
speak to other people right now our
country speaks to people outside our
borders almost exclusively in the
language of violence and I think we have
to reclaim the democratic tradition but
I really don't believe that that's going
to happen unless it Springs from the
grow
roots because I don't see it's bringing
out of the Democratic Party or the
Congress we have just a minute and
pleased to remind you we have all the
panelists at the South signing area line
Z last question here okay how can we all
get attention or problem get the media
to pay attention to the fact that the
u.s. is developing all kinds of nuclear
weapons they backed out of the treaties
and right now all we're getting is
propaganda about Iran you know they're
developing centrifuges but a lot of
people are saying well they don't have
the ability to sustain that for very
long they couldn't possibly develop a
nuclear weapon it would take them ten
years who's the question running for
William perhaps because I'm wanting to
know isn't this propaganda about the
nuclear development in Iran that were
being handed I'm quite sure having
looked at this for quite a long time
that is not propaganda that Iran is
attempting to develop nuclear weapons
and the real surprise is that it's
taking them so long to do it it's just
not that hard to do so the real question
for Americans however and this goes back
to the larger issues it sits at hand
here is how do we react how should we
react to the acquisition of nuclear
weapons by a country like Iran is this
really something we want to go to war
over and I think the answer to that is
no and and there are many reasons for
that so but to say that Iran is not
acquiring nuclear weapons is probably to
play into the hands of the of the
ultra-right in fact I mean if we think
we should admit okay these guys are
doing that and they probably should do
it and then the question is how do we
react but we should point out that
Pakistan has a considerable nuclear
arsenal this administration dropped the
sanctions against Pakistan Conda man who
was responsible for the major
proliferation of weapons to Iran North
Korea and Libya is under house arrest he
has not been waterboarded he has not
even been seen by the CIA so we don't
care about Pakistan's weapons but we've
made a big deal about Iran's
non-existent na right
action I'm Robert just one point on that
I mean as far as Pakistan goes the the
history of the American attitude toward
the acquisition of nuclear weapons by
Pakistan is often criticized by
opponents of American policy but I think
you can also question whether we had any
right to interfere with Pakistan
Pakistan's acquisition of nuclear
weapons and whether it wasn't in fact
legitimate choice by the Government of
Pakistan to acquire nuclear weapons I
think the criticism needs to be a bit
muted by the realities of our own
nuclear arsenals well the you know the
weapons systems in Pakistan Israel and
India were all built in secret none of
those countries signed the nuclear
non-proliferation treaties which Iran
did and what was the message that Iran
god those are of course three of our
major allies the message was don't abide
by the treaty and you better get the
bomb as fast as you can and let's not
forget that Israel has between 300 and
500 weapons and and this has been a
source of great ANC's for those of us
who've lived in the Arab world shorthand
the word Damona Damona Damona is heard
over and over again and I think that not
only should we be working for a nuclear
free Middle East but a nuclear-free
world because trying to to counter one
weapon with another is the road towards
self-annihilation I wanted to end with
these words and it is from Martin Luther
King his essay the trumpet of conscience
40 years ago he said the following
somehow this madness must cease we must
stop now I speak as a child of God and
brother to the suffering poor of Vietnam
I speak for those whose land as being
laid waste whose homes are being
destroyed whose culture is being
subverted I speak for the poor in
America who are paying the double price
of smashed hopes at home and death and
corruption in Vietnam I speak as a
citizen of the world for the world as it
stands aghast at the path we have taken
I speak as an American to the leaders of
my own nation the great
in this war is ours the initiative to
stop it must be ours thank you very much
Thank You Pamela